says peach Bowser and Mario in their
wedding outfits and I just need to ask
you guys about the development process
for these because the the detail of the
sculpting is incredible it must have
been a very interesting process getting
these to the state they're in here
Konami boss Sequoia no come on Heights
critical turning up video that's not
turn into a chocolate mistake that mask
oh hi hello hello in there
peachy mellow Eureka like me dr. K needs
good things so first of all you know
we've got our heroine peach and we
wanted to make sure that you just looked
you know absolutely stunning toku Pato
Mario mo sono whitey de arica Tony juban
not easier to statistics and you know
them from there you know we have Mario
and Bowser as well we had to make sure
that you know in terms of visuals they
weren't going to lose out they got a key
yeah they got a topo Ginga - no more
conga no 10-8 a monogatari still what
acetate in Okotoks two levels and you
know another characteristic of these is
that the posing is very kind of directly
linked with the story and you know
what's going to be happening in the game
yeah Mario's got kind of a humble bow
thing going and Bowser is kind of
looking like I own the world
[Music]
Bowser looks pretty dapper here though
yeah but it is really amazing the I
don't know how close we can get the
camera here we got a better look here
but in person the the texture where some
of them have almost like a pearlized
kind of texture and there's a lot of
subtlety with the the different kinds of
fabric you can really see a lot of
nuance for these ameba we're looking
forward to people seeing them in person
they're gorgeous and I wonder at this
point is there anything you'd like to
share about the functionality of Nebo
for our viewers especially amiibo no
keno say anything
it was costume otech near vaudeville
history at oh ah no game no naka de
notice kiki noticed a ridiculous um so
you'll be able to use the amiibo to get
different costumes within the game and
then they'll also have kind of an assist
function we do have uh existing and me
both are supported as well I think I'll
be talking more about that at a later
point
but I think that's all we're allowed to
show for right now enjoy right now I
will be saying more of this game later
on uh so that's R and of course um but
um of course on a cruisee was on thank
you again so much for joining us here in
chairs for the inside math development
process of the game
yoky think backyard is our stop i think
i thank you and folks are watching